mix them both together well speaking of
healthier food options registered
dietitian mia sin
is back to share some delicious recipes
you might want to give a try during your
health journey let's take a look
hey las vegas now happy new year today i
have some tips on how to eat healthier
in 2021
my first tip is to snack smarter in the
new year by pairing protein and fiber
this combination keeps us full for the
least amount of calories
and will help stabilize blood sugars
until your next meal pair whole grain
crackers and produce with hummus nuts
cheese or meat snacks
chomps meat snacks are made from high
quality protein like grass-fed and
finished beef
and free-range turkey with 9 to 10 grams
of protein per stick
they have no added sugar artificial
preservatives or fillers and come in
delicious varieties
including italian style beef and
jalapeno turkey
my next tip is to cook more meals at
home meals prepared outside the home are
almost
always higher in saturated fat and
sodium and lower in calcium iron and
fiber than meals prepared at home
build nutritious meals at home around
protein produce
carbohydrates and low calorie flavors
like spices fresh herbs and condiments
like salsa
these sheet pan bell pepper chip nachos
check all of your boxes
to a large mixing bowl add fresh produce
toppings of choice
and salsa i'm using the fresh cravings
crisp
authentic tasting salsa made by a family
owned arizona based company with
vine ripened tomatoes and zesty
vegetables it's available in restaurant
style or
chunky you can find it chilled in the
produce section at walmart and smith's
my next tip is to use nutritious ways to
satisfy your sweet tooth in 2021.
these bloom and apples are a nutritious
and fun way to do that
i used these rich red envy apples which
have a crisp texture and balanced
sweetness
they're hard not to fall in love with
they're the ultimate apple perfect for
sharing and savoring
start by slicing off the top of the
apples and use a teaspoon to scoop out
the core
make two circular cuts then place your
apple cut side down on a cutting board
and slice crosswise
brush your apples with a mixture of a
fourth cup of maple syrup and a half
teaspoon of cinnamon and bake for 30
minutes at 400 degrees fahrenheit
finally incorporate immunity supporting
foods and ingredients to stay healthy in
the new year
this immunity coffee and tea by beer
organics is boosted with probiotics and
ingredients like ginger root zinc and
vitamin c
d for immune support the water soluble
immunity water enhancer mixes dissolve
instantly in hot or cold water and
contain immunity supporting ingredients
elderberry echinacea and vitamin c
the elderberry liquid herbal drops are
made with organic antioxidant rich
elderberries and don't require
refrigeration so you can take it on the
go and easily add to water juice or tea
you can find all of these immunity
supporting products at bareorganics.com
and use code mia s20 for 20 off
now i hope you found all of these tips
and recipes helpful you can find them at
my website nutritionbymia.com
and nutritionbymia on instagram where i
also share meal ideas and nutrition tips
daily
see she makes healthy eating look so
good